in gleicher
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz in der nächsten
stunde soll es gehen um die infektions
lage in deutschland und die impf
situation dazu begrüße ich ganz herzlich
unsere gesprächspartner vor dass
gesundheitsminister jens spahn herzlich
willkommen an sie professor dr lothar
wieler er ist präsident des robert koch
institutes und ganz außen hat platz
genommen
professor professor dr klaus cichutek
er ist präsident des
paul-ehrlich-instituts auch ein
herzliches willkommen und dann über
skype zugeschaltet
ich hoffe sie hört uns auch professor
doktor marilyn addo sie ist leiterin der
sektion infektiologie am
universitätsklinikum hamburg-eppendorf
auch ein sie ein herzliches willkommen
zwei vorbemerkungen für die zuschauer
die uns möglicherweise über die live auf
sendung befindlichen fernsehsender hören
die bundespressekonferenz ist keine
institution der bundesregierung sondern
ein unabhängiger verein von
journalistinnen und journalisten die aus
berlin über die bundesregierung und den
bundestag berichten unsere aufgabe ist
es pressekonferenzen zu veranstalten um
unseren mitgliedern die gelegenheit für
fragen zu bieten und die zweite
vorbemerkung dank an den
bundesgesundheitsminister für das
angebot dieses format jetzt zumindest
zeitweise wieder etwas regelmäßiger
stattfinden zu lassen
der vorstand der bundespressekonferenz
und unsere mitgliedschaft dafür
erforderlich dann haben sie das wort
entspannt der dvs and even ev professor
alle meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren danke dann für die gelegenheit
hier erneut die pandemie lage
miteinander zu erörtern
wir verzeichnen gerade einen positiven
trend die zahl der menschen die sich in
deutschland mit dem corona virus
anstecken sinkt sie singt auch schon
seit einigen tagen die sieben tage
incidents liegt seit erstmals seit
langem wieder unter 100 pro 100000 in
den letzten sieben tagen
erreichen in vielen bereichen im moment
werte wie wir sie zuletzt im oktober
gesehen haben das reicht noch nicht
wir wollen weiter runter mit den zahlen
aber es ist ja erst einmal auch
ermutigend denn es zeigt ihr dass die
einschränkungen im privaten und im
öffentlichen leben die hart sind wir für
viele sehr hart sind
tatsächlich aber eben ein unterschied
machen und wirken
gleichzeitig sind inzwischen mehr als
3,5 millionen impfdosen an die länder
gesandt worden übergeben worden davon
sind 2,2 millionen dosen verimpft davon
400.000 bereits zweite impfung also der
vollständige schutz 2,2 prozent der
bevölkerung haben ihre erstimpfungen
damit erhalten
bis mitte februar wollen die länder und
der bund das ist ja ein gemeinsamer
beschluss aus der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz allen
pflegeheimbewohner rennt und
pflegeheimbewohnern ein impf angebot
gemacht haben
stand heute haben 560.000 pflegeheim
bewohnerinnen und bewohner dieses
angebot bekommen
150000 schon zum zweiten weil die zweite
impfung erhalten den vollständigen
schutz wenn wir davon ausgehen dass es
etwa 800.000 bewohnerinnen und bewohner
in pflegeeinrichtungen in deutschland
gibt und nach allem was wir sehen etwa
80 prozent
80 90 prozent jener pflegeeinrichtung
dieses angebot annehmen sind das eben so
etwa 650.000 als zahl die zu erreichen
ist und das zeigt eben wir sind bei
diesem ziel mitte februar auf dem
richtigen weg bei einem guten weg und
das ziel ist darüber hinaus im ersten
quartal voraussichtlich eben allen über
80-jährigen auch ein empfang gebot
machen zu können
das sind wichtige schritte um
insbesondere die besonders verwundbaren
zu schützen
heute wird die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde voraussichtlich
einen weiteren impfstoff zu lassen
wir rechnen nicht mit einer
uneingeschränkten zulassung dafür reicht
ist auch die debatte der letzten tage
die datenlage für ältere nicht aus
übrigens noch mal wichtigsten
unterschied ob die datenlage nicht
ausreicht oder ob sie schlecht ist das
ist sehr wichtig aus meiner sicht für
die kommunikation ein impfstoff der
zugelassen ist ist auch wie gesagt für
diejenigen gruppen
via zugelassen und empfohlen ist und es
ist vor allem auch ein impfstoff der
leichter zu handhaben ist auch das finde
ich ist nochmal ein sehr sehr wichtiger
punkt mit blick auf astra zenica nämlich
bei kühlschrank temperaturen zu lagern
und insgesamt so handhabbare wie es von
vielen anderen impfstoffen auch gewohnt
ich begrüße ausdrücklich die zusage von
astra zenica trotz der
produktionsprobleme die liefermengen an
die europäische union erhöhen zu wollen
das schafft vertrauen in schwieriger
lage und es war und ist gut dass die
europäische kommission als
vertragspartner von astra cdk sich genau
dafür eingesetzt hat und weiter einsetzt
die mitgliedstaaten der europäischen
union haben gemeinsam in die
vorproduktion der impfstoffe investiert
sie haben jetzt auch ein recht darauf
davon zu profitieren dabei geht es eben
nicht um jörg first sondern um den
fairen anteil für die europäische union
dass es bei etwas komplexen wie der
arzneimittelproduktion gerade wenn es so
schnell aufgebaut wird immer auch
rückschläge geben kann
das ist so damit werden wir aller
voraussicht nach auch in den nächsten
wochen an verschiedenen stellen umgehen
müssen
aber es ist wichtig dass es dabei auch
fair zugeht
und das ist eben bestandteil der
gespräche der kommission mit astra
zenica der start der impfkampagne war
schwierig es gibt weniger impfstoff als
wir aus dem europäischen bestellungen
erwartet hatten und die termin hotlines
sind phasenweise schwer erreichbar
die länder leisten unter diesen
schwierigen bedingungen eine gute arbeit
es gibt unterschiedliche strategien und
unterschiedliche gegebenheiten aber alle
länder machen bei den impfungen der
verwundbarsten große fortschritte es ist
wichtig dass bund und länder an einem
strang ziehen und ist aus meiner sicht
auch sehr wichtig für das vertrauen der
bürgerinnen und bürger das sehen wir bei
allen debatten vom beherbergungs verbot
bis zum impfen ist es wichtig für das
vertrauen der bürgerinnen und bürger
dass wir einheitlich agieren und
kommunizieren und deswegen finde ich es
gut dass wir auf einem impfgipfel
auf einem in einer gesprächsrunde von
bund ländern daneben auch gemeinsam mit
vertretern der pharmaindustrie der
hersteller und der europäischen union
die lage erörtern
es geht zuerst einmal darum gemeinsame
gewissheiten über die lage zu entwickeln
was ist möglich aber im übrigen auch
realistisch einzuschätzen was ist nicht
möglich jedenfalls nicht in zwei oder
vier wochen etwa mit blick auf impfstoff
produktion und das und die andere fragen
sind sicherlich die themen die uns
beschäftigen werden für mich ist wichtig
dass wir damit auch eine gemeinsame
basis finden für die weitere debatte die
größte impfaktion der geschichte ist
eine gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe
es gibt auch gute nachrichten der
produktionsstandort in marburg hat
gestern eine genehmigung bekommen hat
sich ausgezahlt dass die bundesregierung
dass das land hessen das
regierungspräsidium vor ort dafür seit
mitte vergangenen jahres gemeinsam mit
dem unternehmen stark gearbeitet haben
sanofi ist eine kooperation auch mit
bajonett eingegangen für produktion in
frankfurt also auch bei uns in
deutschland es gibt weitere
kooperationen auch mit produzenten die
chemische industrie bringt sich in
großem umfang ein
und auch dort neben für weg und bayer
die kooperieren auch das eine gute
nachricht für den standort deutschland
aus alldem heraus sehen wir idee des
allegro farm hamburg viele viele
unternehmen größere und kleinere die
vielleicht nicht immer präsent waren in
den letzten jahren in der öffentlichen
berichterstattung sind aber tatsächlich
perlen der impfstoff produktion und
entwicklung auf der welt und die agieren
und das auch nicht erst vor zwei wochen
in dieser pandemie zusammen und das ist
gut mit den impfstoffen von koubek und
johnson & johnson werden wir
voraussichtlich im zweiten quartal
rechnen können das ziel ist weiter im
sommer allen ein impf angebot machen zu
können
meine damen und herren wir leben in und
mit der größten krise seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg
diese krise ist für jeden von uns eine
herausforderung für die wissenschaft für
die politik für die gesellschaft viele
menschen leiden
unter der aktuellen situation und iran
viele sind auch frustiert frustriert bei
der impfstoffe am anfang sehr knapp ist
ich kann diese ungeduld verstehen aber
zur wahrheit gehört eben auch es lägen
noch einige harte wochen der knappheit
des impfstoffes vor uns ich wichtig
finde zu sehen der weg heraus aus dieser
jahrhundert pandemie ist begonnen dass
es nur zwölf monate nach dem ausbruch
der pandemie drei wirkungsvolle
impfstoffe bereits gibt und weitere vor
der zulassung stehen ist eine
erfolgsgeschichte eine einmalige
erfolgsgeschichte in der medizin
das sollte uns unter einem stress auch
zuversicht geben dank ersparen herr
professor ihnen jeden tag meine damen
und herren wir sind auf einem guten weg
und wir müssen diesen weg weiter
konsequent bestreiten die gesamte
inzidenz geht weiter zurück gestern am
donnerstag lag sie zum ersten mal seit
ende oktober letzten jahres wieder unter
der 100 von 100.000 einwohnern in sieben
tagen wir sehen aber dass die inzidenz
eigentlich nur in den vier am stärksten
betroffenen bundesländern zurück geht
das ist thüringen sachsen anhalt
brandenburg und sachsen
in den anderen zwölf bundesländern ist
sie in den letzten sieben tagen nahezu
gleich geblieben und es gibt trotz der
maßnahmen auch einzelne landkreise in
denen die inzidenz durch lokale
ausbrüche auch wieder zunimmt es
infizieren sie insgesamt also immer noch
zu viele menschen mit saas kopf zwei wir
gehen zurzeit von rund 238.000 aktiven
fällen aus und wir sehen leider nach wie
vor viele ausbrüche in alten und
pflegeheimen und die intensivstation
meine damen und herren sind immer noch
sehr belastet auch wenn die gesamtzahl
an its patienten in den meisten
bundesländern jetzt langsam zurückgeht
und leider sterben weiterhin sehr viele
menschen in verbindung mit coop 19
bis heute sind dem robert koch institut
insgesamt 55 1752 todesfälle übermittelt
worden
alle diese informationen auch zahlen und
kartenmaterial finden sie auf dem
dashboard und in täglichen
situationsbericht des robert koch
instituts auf unserer website www.iaa.de
was uns im robert-koch-institut sorge
bereitet das sind die neuen noch
ansteckenden varianten des virus es
werden immer mehr fälle und auch
ausbrüche durch diese varianten gemeldet
wir kennen die eigenschaften der
varianten noch nicht vollständig wir
wissen noch nicht ob sie auch
gefährlicher sind und bei einigen
varianten wissen wir auch nicht ob
menschen die bereits an cupid 19
erkrankt waren oder geimpft wurden ob
diese menschen wirklich immun gegen die
neuen varianten sind
das wird im moment erforscht in vielen
teilen der welt
wir müssen aber davon ausgehen wenn sich
die noch ansteckende 'ran varianten
hierzulande weiter ausbreiten dann
werden sie zu noch mehr fällen in kurzer
zeit führen und dann würde sich die lage
möglicherweise auch wieder verschlimmern
und dass man damen und herren das müssen
wir gemeinsam verhindern einen neuen
starken anstieg an fallzahlen würden die
intensivstationen derzeit definitiv
nicht verkraften wir müssen natürlich
einen besseren überblick darüber
bekommen welche varianten wo zirkulieren
und wir müssen auch neue mutationen so
rasch wie möglich erkennen
dafür werden wir jetzt deutlich mehr
viren sequenziert als vorher und sollte
im 19 januar ist die korona virus owens
verordnung in kraft getreten und was
sieht sie vor erstens dass laboren
deutlich mehr proben als bisher
sequenzieren
zweitens dass die sequenzdaten mit den
fall daten der gesundheitsämter zentral
im robert-koch-institut zusammengeführt
werden
drittens das ziel ist dass mindestens
fünf prozent aller positiven
probensequenz analysiert werden und
viertens dass die datenbasis also stetig
wächst damit aber eines muss klar sein
auch die beste molekulare methode bringt
es natürlich nur dann mehr wissen wenn
sie sinnvoll mit klassischen
infektions epidemiologischen methoden
gekoppelt sind es ist also nicht ein ent
oder ein weder sondern es ist das
gesamtkonzept und das haben wir als
robert koch-institut immer im blick und
eines möchte ich auch noch einmal an der
stelle betonen der goldstandard für die
primär diagnostik ist und bleibt
natürlich die pcr und im zweiten schritt
erfolgen kann zielgerichtet eine sequenz
analyse mandant kann mit jeder reise mit
jedem kontakt mit jeder ungetragen oder
falsch getragene maske bieten wir den
virus die gelegenheit sich weiter zu
verbreiten und das virus das ist ein
typischer gelegenheitstäter
es verfolgt keinen plan sondern ergreift
jede gelegenheit die wir ihnen bieten
jedes mal wenn wir zu hause bleiben
statt zu reisen wenn wir jemanden
anrufen anstatt vorbei zu gehen wenn wir
uns an die a h und l regeln halten
reduzieren wir die gefahr dass der
gelegenheitstäter saß kauf zwei
zuschlägt der beste plan den wir alle
haben ist dass wir nicht reisen und so
kontakte reduzieren und uns immer und
überall an die a h und l regeln halten
und dieser plan wird mit jedem der
mittwoch effektiver halten wir uns
weiterhin an diesen planen und wenn sie
sich einmal nicht daran halten konnten
dann geben sie nicht auf nach einem
vermeidbaren kontakt oder nach einer
ungetragen maske aufzugeben
das wären etwa so wie nach einer
autofahrt ohne sicherheitsgurt generell
aufzuhören sich an die verkehrsregeln zu
halten weil es jetzt ja eh nicht mehr
darauf ankäme und meine damen und herren
wenn sie eine impfung angeboten bekommen
bitte lassen sie sich impfen das ist der
wirksamste schutz gegen kuwait 19 den
weg geben können geben wir diesen cupid
19 keine chance danke stabiler prophet
tätig
ich möchte von meiner seite eine gewisse
zwischenbilanz geben
hinsichtlich der sicherheit der
impfstoffe die zugelassen sind und ich
glaube vielleicht zunächst beginnen
werden statement hinsichtlich der
bevorstehenden zulassung des astra
zeneca impfstoffs wie herr minister aus
geführt hat ist das eine ausgezeichnete
leistung nicht nur der entwickler auch
der regulatorischen behörden auch der
akademischen forschung darunter dass wir
innerhalb von im wesentlichen einem jahr
nach erkennen eines neues virus mehrere
impfstoff produkte zugelassen haben und
ich kann ihnen versichern und hier haben
wir glaube ich auch das vertrauen der
bürgerinnen und bürger gerechtfertigt
dass diese impfstoffe nach allen regeln
der kunst geprüft wurden
wir haben flexibilität gezeigt um ihr
schneller zu sein
die industrie hat kooperationen gesucht
und wir synergien zu schaffen aber
insgesamt haben alle einen handstand
gezogen um zu diesem ergebnis zu kommen
während wir hier sitzen in dieser
pressekonferenz tagt der ausschuss für
humanarzneimittel bei der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur in dem auch das
paul-ehrlich-institut vertreten ist und
ich kann ihnen sagen ohne das ergebnis
vorweg greifen zu wollen dass die vor
diskussionen in der woche natürlich heiß
gelaufen sind das aber die wesentlichen
grundlagen geschaffen wurden um
wahrscheinlich zu einer empfehlung zu
kommen für eine zulassung ohne
altersbegrenzung aber via minister aus
geführt hat wird darauf hingewiesen
werden möglicherweise dass die datenlage
etwas schwächer ist bei älteren personen
das heißt aber dass trotzdem wirksamkeit
da ist und sie wissen das die grundlage
für die zulassung sein muss gerade bei
impfstoffen dass der nutzen weit
überwiegend gegenwärtigen risiken die
zweite erfreuliche nachricht besteht
darin dass wir sehr schnell impfstoffe
geprüft haben
alle notwendigen voraussetzungen
geschaffen damit die impfstoffe
qualitätsgesichert hergestellt werden
können und die entsprechende qualität
regina auch dem hohen standard
entsprechen der üblich ist bei
impfstoffen die eher präventiv wirken an
millionen erwachsenen dann auch kindern
und jugendlichen angewandt werden die
größtenteils gesund sind und die an
gesundheit natürlich erhalten sollen
wir können sagen dass das ergebnis ist
unsere regulatorischen begleitung dass
wir jetzt auch macht den impfung sehen
und wir verfolgen aktiv über
verdachtsfall meldungen was in
deutschland passiert welche reaktionen
auftreten bei den geimpften wir würden
auch zwischenfälle mitbekommen und
können sagen dass das was wir in der
entwicklung gesehen haben und was die
grundlage für die zulassung war auch
sich jetzt bestätigt ihm fällt nach den
etwa 1,72 millionen geimpften ich darf
darauf hinweisen dass wir da transparent
jede meldung darstellen sie werden eine
zusammenfassung der zwischenberichte
wöchentlich von uns bekommen wie es im
moment aussieht etwa am donnerstag von
den ergebnissen die wir am sonntagabend
haben dass da ein gewisser teil blick
ist liegt nicht daran dass wir so lange
brauchen und vielleicht nicht so schnell
arbeiten sondern die daten müssen ja
gewissenhaft sortiert werden auch nach
gerechnet werden
das ist ganz wichtig was ist das
ergebnis nun einmal ist bestätigt sich
dass die bekannte neben fraktionen die
nach drei bis fünf tagen wieder an
abgesehen und kann die schäden
hinterlassen auftreten
das sind die reaktionen schmerzen
druckstelle an der injektionsstelle
gleich kopfschmerz leichtes unwohlsein
leichtes fieber dass es bekannt und
diese verträglichkeits reaktionen
bestätigen sich jetzt auch ein feld und
sie sind mild bis moderat
das zweite ist
wir wussten ja schon aus anhalten der
klinischen prüfungen dass es im
einzelfall sehr seltener anaphylaktische
reaktion gibt wir haben inzwischen 22
gesicherte reaktionen gemeldet bekommen
können sagen dass nicht ganz klar ist
auch auf diese zurückgehen aber wir
haben wir vorsorglich schon dafür
gesorgt dass innen im zentrum da wo wie
im vorjahr die ärzte die entsprechend
geimpften mindestens 15 minuten lang
weiter beobachten und dann auch
eingreifen können mit der entsprechenden
notfallversorgung falls eine
anaphylaktische reaktion auf drückt aber
nochmal diese sind sehr selten und die
entsprechenden betroffenen erholen sich
davon eine zweite diskussion betraf die
todesfälle
wir haben 69 todesfälle gemeldet
bekommen die entsprechenden verstorbenen
hatten ein alter zwischen 6 und 50 und
100 jahren
das ist der priorisierung geschuldet
dass moment vorwiegend ältere geimpft
werden
die todesfälle traten eine stunde bis 18
tage nach der impfung auf das
wesentliche ist wenn sie sich angucken
was die erwartete inzidenz sterberate in
diesem personenkreis ist so liegen die
sterberaten die gemeldet wurden nach der
impfung darunter das heißt es gibt
keinen grund anzunehmen dass sie von der
impfung verursacht wurden ebenso verhält
es sich mit den umständen
es handele sich häufig um personen mit
grunderkrankungen und klaus siebel dass
diese grunderkrankung zu versterben
geführt habe der dritte fall betraf die
fast alles paris die gesichtslähmung
auch hier gibt es guten achten sehr sehr
selten
einige haben wir gemeldet bekommen die
sich dann auch wieder zurückbilden und
auch hier kann ich entwarnung geben
das heißt insgesamt haben wir es mit
impfstoffen zu tun die von millionen
sehr gut vertragen wäre
und die auch den notwendigen schutz dann
ergeben werden den wir erwarten wie
verfolgt das paul-ehrlich-institut dies
wir beruhen einmal darauf dass wir ja
immer schon etabliertes system zur
kontrolle der sicherheit von
arzneimitteln und biomedizinischen unter
anderem arzneimittel aufgebaut haben wir
sind auch teil eines europäischen
überwachungssystems hier gibt es eine
datenbank die auch europaweit die
entsprechende meldung eingespeist hat
auch diese ergebnisse korrelieren mit
den ergebnissen die ich ihm vorgetragen
habe es ist weiterhin sodass wir
verdachtsfälle selber von seiten des
paul-ehrlich-instituts aufnehmen diese
bewerten den einzelnen nachgehen ich
muss in die meldung vollständig das hat
zu dem ergebnis geführt dass sie
geschildert habe wir bieten geimpften
personen eine app an und damit nehmen
sie an einer beobachtungsstudie
freiwillig teil in dieser sammeln wir
ebenfalls aktiv die reaktionen die diese
person erlitten haben und wir werden
hier in zusammenarbeit mit dem mercury
auch nachhören
ob es fälle von kunden gegeben hat und
bekommen einen eindruck von der
effektivität wie sie sagen also der
wirksamkeit der impfstoffe im feld ich
möchte kurz auch noch mal klar sagen
dass sie wissen es gibt um die
impfstoffe eine ganze reihe von fake
news
ich kann nur dazu aufrufen behördlich
gesicherte informationen nach zu suchen
auf der webpage des rk ii auf der
webpage des paul-ehrlich-instituts da
finden sie informationen die valide sind
und diese informationen besagen dass es
keinen hinweis darauf gibt keine
grundlage dafür dass die impfstoffe in
irgendeiner form den menschen oder
seinen körper zellen genetisch
modifizierten würden und es gibt auch
keinen hinweis darauf dass es probleme
mit der fruchtbarkeit geben wird oder
anderer fällt muss um sie herum
schwirren
das ist alles quatsch sie wissen dass
wir mit dem astra zeneca impfstoff einen
weiteren impfstoff bekommen werden der
bezug auf lagerung und transport seine
vorteile hat
er ist als vektor impfstoff etwas anders
von der technologie gelagert als diana
impfstoffe wir haben mit vectoring
stoffen schon im e-book-bereich
erfahrungen und wir wissen auch dass die
wirksamkeit im klinischen prüfung
ermittelt wurde
etwas geringer ist als bei den jetzt
schon zugelassenen impfstoffen
aber ich kann ihnen sagen dass aus
modellrechnung hervor geht dass sie in
dieser lage solche impfstoffe ein
wichtiger beitrag sind um die pandemie
zu bekämpfen und das wichtige ist wenn
diese impfstoffe zugelassen sind regulär
mit aller sorgfalt die ich ihnen
versichern kann dann sind sie gut und
dann können sie eingesetzt werden dann
werden sie effektiv sein
in der pandemie bekämpfen und die bevor
haben ja das sind zu meiner seite guten
achten sie nachrichten sie können sich
darauf verlassen dass wir auch weiterhin
transparent hier agieren werden und zu
können sie auch darauf verlassen dass
wir weiterhin mit vielen vielen
entwicklern und herstellern in kontakt
sind wir werden seitens
paul-ehrlich-institut gesucht um hier
unsere regulatorische erfahrung
einzubringen und können auf diese weise
dafür sorgen dass noch mehr impfstoffe
den hatten entwicklungsfähig
schnellstens nehmen werden so dass wir
weitere zulassungen haben werden
die namen sind genannt worden die an zum
klärwerk nowaks zeigen gute ergebnisse
viele andere sind in der phase 3
dankeschön dankeschön und dann vor
professoren morgen ist das sparen sie
morgen melden und herren
aus hamburg die tatsache dass ich in
dieser form an der pressekonferenz
teilnehmen soll ja auch ein beitrag
gleich ein system was entweder schon
gesagt hat seine kontakte reduzieren und
halt nicht nach berlin reisen
wir haben jetzt auch schon ein wenig
über das thema impfen unterhalten und
das thema hat ja in den letzten wochen
die emotionen sehr hoch schlagen lassen
damit ist auch verständlich wie der
minister stand schon sagte ist das ein
wichtiger teil unserer strategie aus
dieser pandemie heraus und insofern es
ist natürlich etwas was die gesellschaft
auch erwartet ich denke nun durch diese
ganzen und möchte das auch noch mal
betonen sowie auch ersparen
in seinem eingangsstatement dass wir den
blick auf das was erreicht wurde nicht
verlegt verlieren dürften also wenn wir
noch mal zurückschauen ein elfter januar
2009 und 20 ist das neue virus
sequenziert worden die sequenz wurde
verfügbar und nur zwei monate später am
16 märz ist die erste person in einer
klinischen prüfung einem der jetzt
zugelassenen impfstoffe gegeben worden
das ist allein schon ein
wissenschaftlicher ab werk der grandiose
sind diese eben stoff und zwei von
diesen impfstoffen ab und der modernen
technologie im erwin stache beruht haben
dann auch noch eine zulassung bekommen
im jahr 2020 also in weniger als einem
jahr das ist wirklich eine leistung die
auch das runter geht in der kritischen
betrachtung viele aspekte die es
vielleicht auch nicht optimal gelaufen
sind aber dass wir überhaupt hier
angekommen sind und gibt zwei und jetzt
mal drei zugelassene impfstoffe haben
werden nicht ruhen wirksamkeit die
beiden in ihrer werkstatt waren wir über
90 prozent der gesamtheit gezeigt wir
werden dafür holte sicherlich von der
eben noch mal transportiert bekommt
zudem hast das amerikanische bestanden
dass das was wir hier sind es ist auch
nicht selbstverständlich weil die
entwicklung wirklich ein komplexer
prozess ist und wir haben ja jetzt auch
gesehen dass während er über weit über
200 endlich gestartet
einige jetzt schon noch gerade in den
letzten wochen wie er von sandra auf
probleme hatten oder zum teil ganz aus
der innenstadtentwicklung ausgestiegen
sind das ist nicht selbstverständlich
dass wir jetzt hier sind mit produkten
die und jetzt schon zugelassen sind oder
auch noch weitere folgen
und das sollten wir auch wenig frei wir
haben ja auch in diesem
entwicklungsprozess ganz rigoros die
verschiedenen phasen der klinischen
entwicklung durchlaufen in der phase 1
wird die sicherheit und ihre mobilität
geprüft und wir haben uns vielleicht
auch sehr viel konzentrieren immer auch
die sicherheit aber natürlich wenn ein
impfstoff nicht die ausreichende in
honolulu täter sind nicht ausreichend
antikörper zum beispiel erfolgt dann
geht das entwicklungsprogramm auch nicht
weiter sondern muss dann noch mal
geprüft werden und das ist zum beispiel
entwicklern in den letzten wochen vor
kurzem ist er zum beispiel ist derart
mit seinen stoffen aus der entwicklung
ausrichten
in der phase 2 wird auch geht so weiter
sicherheitsdaten und dosis finden und
haben auch die jetzt schon zugelassenen
impfstoffe zum beispiel moderne hatte
drei impfstoffdosen und hat dann in
dieser phase entschieden welche dosis
geimpft wird
das waren die mittlere von den
getesteten also sind auch die wichtigen
elemente der erwin stoff entwicklung
muss hier ganz gründungs eingehalten
worden und in der phase 3 und natürlich
die wirksamkeitsstudien von denen wir
auch weiterhin sehr gute ergebnisse
berichtet werden was natürlich umtreibt
am main wieder hat es ist eben schon
erwähnt sind in rotation und die
mutationen in einem königreich und in
brasilien um den südafrika aufgetreten
sind die machen wir natürlich nicht nur
mit sorge oder wachsamkeit im zug auf
das
infektionsgeschehen die ausbreitung und
die schwere der erkrankung sondern
natürlich ergeben sich daraus auch
fragen zur wirksamkeit der impfstoffe
und das ist jetzt ein thema das sehr
aktiv geforscht wird und man muss sagen
gerade mitzutragen
es gab es hier sehr erfreuliche und
hoffnungsfrohe nachrichten die
entwickler moderner und sonntag haben
mit wissenschaftlern aus den usa und
verschiedene arbeitsgruppen haben
tatsächlich virus mandanten um ihre
ihrem gebaut
die diese mutanten die aufgetreten die
mutation die aufgetreten sind auch in
sich vereinen und konnten zeigen dass
clasmann von geimpften einem aktivität
weiterhin hat diese viren zu
neutralisieren das wurde gestern
berichtet und die daten werden wir
sicherlich auch noch genau uns anschauen
können eine davon zum update server
verfügbar
und das sind sicherlich sehr positive
signale
gerade gestern und herstellt rande
erwähnt sind ja noch einige andere
entwickler in der klinischen prüfung
gerade er gestern sind die erste option
ist man ja also metall blickte
herausgekommen dass ihren laufenden
phase 3 studien auch eine wirksamkeit
gegen demonstranten tatsächlich
mutationen auch in die klinischen
prüfungen gezeigt wurde und als fake
auch nochmal ist uns ja am anfang oder
blau des letzten jahres oft die frage
gestellt
und jetzt haben wir schon zwei
instrumente vorne sind brauchen die
ganzen anderen entwicklungsprogramme
noch einmal gesagt wurde es breit
aufstellen und wir haben ja eine große
bevölkerung zu beginn aber jetzt ist
natürlich auch das zeitliche verzug
sogar ein vorteil oder zumindest ergibt
ergibt sich die möglichkeit also der
klinischen prüfung die jetzt laufen auch
die mobile stationen der bevölkerung ist
jetzt ausgebreitet haben zu testen und
zu sehen auch tatsächlich die impfstoffe
noch sagen sie und gegen diese mutation
und diese ersten berichte von entwickler
nummer wachs von gestern aus über afrika
und aus uk zeigen dass da auch klinische
besteht und nicht nur in diesem labor
studium also insgesamt soll ich sagen es
ist ein grund zur hoffnung auch aus
israel werden ja auch so dass andere
geimpft wurde
kommen wir jetzt auch taten das
tatsächlich auch im feld wirksamkeit
schon belegt ist und diese werke werden
wir in deutschland sicherlich auch bald
generieren können wird man weiter
aufpassen müssen und diese mutation
verfolgung auf jeden fall ist wenn mir
sicherlich muss man genauso wie wir das
jetzt auch im rahmen der erweiterten
sequenziert möglichkeiten für das
infektionsgeschehen uns anschauen müssen
wir auch weiter testen wie diese
mutation eventuell einen einfluss auf
die täter über die impfstoffe
wirksamkeit haben
das ist sicherlich ein auftrag den der
nächsten monate und jahre vielleicht
auch noch begleiten wird
aber die guten news hier sind trotzdem
auch dass wir natürlich mit dieser
technologie die ich am anfang erwähnt
habe nur zwei monate bis zur ersten
klinischen prüfung und immer sagen es
dauert nur wochen ist eine arena im
stoff neu entwickelt werden kann
dann haben wir auch ein tool das auch um
stoffe sehr schnell anpassen kann
falls das nötig sein sollte momentan
gibt es keinen grund dafür dass das
nötig ist aber die entwickler haben sich
auch da schon so bekannt dass es möglich
ist und dass wir reagieren könnten und
neue impfstoff konstrukte die dann
spezifisch für neue varianten entwickelt
werden dagegen neue variante entwickelt
werden auch in die entwicklung bringen
können also insgesamt und wir da glaube
ich sehr gut aufgestellt und so weit
würde ich uns allen geduld noch wir
haben
ich sag mal so wir haben die tools in
hass in sichtbarer greifweite sind zwei
schon zugelassen ein dritter kommt dazu
andere produkte werden mit
wahrscheinlich relativ zügig folgen die
auch von gute ergebnisse gezeigt haben
die wirtschaft vor allem geduld und
altvermögen das will den blick nicht
verlieren das in der richtigen richtung
unterwegs sind und also ich persönlich
sehe das glas halb leer sondern eher als
halb voll und wünsche uns dass wir
hoffentlich in einem halben jahr über
ganz andere dinge berichten können
herzlichen dank dann kommen wir zu
fragen ich habe schon über 20
wortmeldungen hier liegen das wären wir
unmöglich schaffen in der zur verfügung
stehenden zeit ich bitte deshalb um
disziplin bei der fragestellung aber
auch um disziplin bei der beantwortung
die erste frage hatte wacket jetzt bin
ich etwas überrascht über die frage das
ist genau das was passiert ist vor zwei
drei wochen
die ema hat die zulassung erteilt auch
für die sechste dose daraufhin sind
bezogen auf die flasche die dosen zur
verfügung stehen neu berechnet worden
und seitdem rechnen wir ja auch so das
hätte auch in deutschland und für europa
zu 20 prozent mehr geführt
und wenn es nicht in pools dann zu den
produktionsausfällen phasenweise
gekommen wäre
aber in den usa wissen sie was mich ja
ich soll nicht immer ich soll nicht
immer über medienberichterstattung reden
soll nicht immer über
medienberichterstattung reden sagt der
coach aber wenn in den usa 200 millionen
dosen mehr entstehen weil die sechste
dose mitgezählt wird dann wird das zu
großen erfolg in deutschland die sechste
lose mitgezählt wird dann wird gesagt
wie konnte das jetzt passieren jetzt
haben wir irgendwie
auf einmal nur durch rechnungen mehr
aber nicht wirklich
also es ist in beiden fällen die greife
grundlage
es ist durch das um labeln das auch in
der eu schon passiert ist durch immer
entscheidung 20 prozent mehr an dosen
verfügbar
das machte sich ja auch schon bemerkbar
letzte woche als über 800.000 dosen
geliefert wurden statt nur 670.000 in
dieser woche hat fürs voll zugeschlagen
nämlich dass die produktionskapazität
entsprechend niedriger war
hätten wir nicht diese sechste dose
wären in dieser woche nicht über 400.000
impfdosen verfügbar gewesen sondern
weniger und so setzte sich in den
nächsten wochen fort also den usa ist
zeitlich später in diesem fall das
passiert was in europa schon passiert
war dass die zusage von pfizer bei uns
ist das ab mitte februar das
ausgeglichen wird genau aber demnächst
das ist nämlich gute punkte die mir
dankbar für die frage ich habe die
meldung auch gesehen gedacht bekommen es
die 200 million dosen her
sie kommen eben vor allem aus dieser
umrechnung von 5 auf 6
er hatte
gerne sind ja mit dem monoklonalen
antikörper medikamente die noch nicht
zugelassen sind sondern die wir als
bundesministerium für gesundheit in
verkehr bringen
nach vorheriger intensiven austausch
auch über leitlinien und empfehlungen
mit den fachgesellschaften dem robert
koch institut im paul-ehrlich-institut
insbesondere auch als zuständige
zulassungsbehörde und es ist ja nicht so
dass die unikliniken sie ausschließlich
zur verfügung haben sie werden verteilt
über die unikliniken auch in andere
kliniken und in andere bereiche hinein
aber es macht ihm gleichzeitig auch sinn
aufgrund der besonderen lage noch nicht
zugelassen sie eben auch unter dieser
beobachtung denn dann in die versorgung
zu geben
aber natürlich können kooperationen auch
kliniken haben den übrigen ambulante
versorgungsmöglichkeiten sie auch in
anderen bereichen eingesetzt werden ich
weiß von vielen kliniken die sie nutzen
zum beispiel auch bei ausbrüchen
benutzen wollen besser gesagt
bei ausbrüchen in der klinik zum
beispiel oder eben bei patienten die
sich frühzeitig zeigen und mit jedem mit
jeder anwendung werden ja weitere
erkenntnisse gewonnen und dann wird man
sie zug um zug etwa klassischer fall
wäre zum beispiel auch ein ausbruch in
einer pflegeeinrichtung wo das risiko
von schwersten verläufen sehr hoch ist
und wurde an die entscheidung des arztes
daneben sein soll und kann im einzelfall
die auch zur anwendung zu bringen
wir müssen ja auch in welcher der
verteilung und die geht eben über die
unikliniken in die kliniken die mit
denen kooperieren in die weiteren
bereich ich habe eine reihe von fragen
online die sich alle um den impfstoff
astrazeneca drehen unter anderem vom
kollegen dankbar oder von kollegen
heller zur klarheit fragt der kollege
hält zum beispiel der astrazeneca
impfstoff wird vermutlich ohne
altersbeschränkung begrenzung von der
ema zugelassen fragezeichen von der
ständigen impfkommission aber gibt es
die empfehlung mit altersbegrenzung
wie passt das zusammen und verdammt
bleibt dann also deutschland dabei
erledigt in der altersgruppe unter 65
jahren zu kämpfen und es gibt auch noch
fragen
die könnte man vielleicht damit gleich
mit beantworten wie ist es damit der imf
reihenfolge der übrigen irgend freien
folge wenn dann im zweifel impfstoff zur
verfügung steht die frage anfang
vielleicht mal an und wenn sie einen
nachbarn sind würde herr professor jack
noch hecking also macht zum ersten ich
kann halt nur dafür werben nicht zuletzt
auch um vertrauen zu erhalten dass wir
wir jedenfalls werden das tun die
reihenfolge auch einhalten
erst wird zugelassen durch die
europäische arzneimittelagentur die
entscheidung erwarten wir heute in
dieser entscheidung der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur werden wir dann
sehen ob es hinweise gibt seitens der
zulassungsbehörde bezogen auf das alter
das ist nicht unwahrscheinlich dass es
diese hinweise geben wird in der
zulassung nach allem was wir bisher aus
den diskussionen wissen aber wir müssen
es halt erst wenn die entscheidung
getroffen ist und vor allem wie stark
diese hinweise seien werden werden dass
hinweise seien die die zulassung
beschränken oder sind es hinweise die
sagen keine beschränkung aber vorsicht
in einem bestimmten bereich weil die
daten nicht da sind wenn diese
entscheidung heute getroffen ist wird
die ständige impfkommission anschließend
eine empfehlung aussprechen
gestern war ein entwurf einer empfehlung
der kursierte die reihenfolge ist aber
weiterhin immer entscheidet danach auf
basis der entscheidung der ema die
ständige impfkommission wenn die
ständige impfkommission entschieden
haben wird
das wird sie dann auch in den nächsten
tagen tun zeitnah werden wir die
impfverordnung auf der basis
gegebenenfalls anpassen und daneben
möglicherweise was beschränkung angeht
oder nicht daraus schlussfolgerungen
ziehen aber ich kann ja nicht die
impfverordnung anpassen bevor die ebene
überhaupt zugelassen hat also ich finde
schon sehr wichtig dass wir einfach auch
fachlich sachlich und prozessual die
reihenfolge einhalten weil alles andere
eben auch aber es ist wichtig für das
vertrauen das ist meine feste
überzeugung zulassung stiko empfehlung
im verordnung wird angepasst und daraus
können sich die dinge ergeben die die
letzten zwei tage drei tage schon
diskutiert worden sind bezogen auf die
altersgruppe ergänzen
ich kann da wenig ergänzt das ist völlig
korrekt dargestellt ist es so dass
unsere entscheidung im ausschuss für
humanarzneimittel unterliegt zu prüfen
gibt es gute daten die nach dem pre
design der klinischen prüfung dann auch
gezeigt haben dass ein nutzen da ist das
übersetzt sich in wirksamkeit dass es
gegeben bei diesem impfstoff er hat sehr
gute wirksamkeit und es kann sein dass
während der stellungnahme ich hatte ja
schon erläutert was wir jetzt gerade die
sitzung quasi parallel durchführen
entschieden wird das ein hinweis in der
entsprechenden fach und
gebrauchsinformationen darauf gegeben
wird dass die datenlage bei höheren
altersgruppen etwas schwächer ist als
bei den anderen ansonsten ist das aber
sehr gut die evidenz für wirksamkeit
auch bei diesem impfstoff sehr gute
evidenz für seine sicherheit und die
ständige impfkommission hat auch einige
andere aspekte zu berücksichtigen
auch gerade in bezug auf die lage in
deutschland und ich glaube wir müssen
die diskussion dann aufnehmen wenn die
entscheidung gefällt ist jetzt gerade
ist ja gelegenheit hier auch nochmal die
entsprechenden daten zu prüfen auch die
vorschläge der impfkommission das wird
sich in den nächsten tagen passieren
herfried
[Musik]
okay aber wie gehabt unter der prämisse
immer steko impfverordnung gleichwohl
wie gesagt ist ja seit herbst bekannt
dass es bei dem daten im umfang der
daten die es für ältere gibt in der
astra zenica studie jedenfalls die
datengrundlage deutlich kleiner ist als
bei anderen zuerst einmal wir rechnen
stand heute mit etwa 12 millionen dosen
bei montech moderner bis zum ablauf des
ersten quartals stand heute da ist die
gerade diskutierte mengensteigerung die
pfizer angekündigt hatte noch nicht
eingerechnet
mit diesen zwölf millionen dosen können
wir jedenfalls im größten teil der preo
gruppe 1 auch ein empfang gebot machen
im ersten quartal werden jetzt von
astrazeneca eine zulassung heute erfolgt
und als frau zenica schon angekündigt
hat etwa 17 millionen dosen mindestens
im nächsten moment etwas haben heute den
19 im nächsten monat studium im februar
dann an die eu transportieren liefern zu
können dann werden das für deutschland
etwa drei millionen dosen wenn das so
eintritt wie astra zenica als
angekündigt hat diese drei millionen
dosen sind ja bis jetzt sind sozusagen
in
noch nicht irgendwie der terminvergabe
oder so hinterlegt wir können ja erst
planen wenn wir den sicheren lieferplan
haben aber die machen natürlich ein
unterschied also damit können wir ja
viele menschen impfen
und dann werden wir eben auf basis der
entscheidung der stiko und dann der
impfverordnung die wir natürlich dann
zügig über arbeiten werden und wie
gesagt in der gerade genannten
reihenfolge wird es ja auch in anderen
trio also schon in der priorisierung
gruppe 1 gibt es ja leute unter 80 die
priorisiert sind das pflegepersonal
diejenigen die auf den intensivstationen
arbeiten die selbst in den impfzentren
arbeiten gibt es viele die unter 80 und
unter 65 sind in der periode 2 gibt es
weiteres medizinisches personal und
menschen mit vorerkrankungen die
besondere risiken haben die unter 65
sind das heißt also wir werden auch
einen impfstoff der möglicherweise
bestimmte altersgruppen eben empfohlen
ist zur verschiffung sinnvoll nutzen
können wirklich sinnvoll zum mehrwert
für den einzelnen und für schutz von
menschen die in einem besonderen risiko
sind nutzen können und damit wird jeder
zugelassene impfstoff der wirksam ist
für alle bevölkerungsgruppen oder für
bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen einen
unterschied machen und uns in unserer
impfkampagne helfen
[Musik]
nein das heißt das nicht
astrazeneca hat ja begonnen mit studien
in den vereinigten staaten in südamerika
wenn ich's richtig weiß in verschiedenen
stellen oben zusätzliche daten zu
generieren wenn die schon ausreichend
sozusagen zu ergebnissen geführt hätten
wären sie eingeflossen jetzt in die
immer entscheidung wenn die daten
nachgeliefert werden dann kann ja eine
solche entscheidung der ema daneben nach
gelieferten daten auch angepasst werden
also astra zenica war ja soweit ich das
wahrgenommen hat selbst nicht glücklich
über das was war nicht nur diese
diskussion es gab ja im herbst ein paar
themen rund um die studie und hat
daraufhin neue studien begonnen
mit jeder neuen studien auswertungen und
datenlage die da ist werden natürlich
bestehende entscheidungen dann ergänzt
oder überarbeitet
eine kurze ergänzung zur diskussion das
ist auch etwas was sich die
medienvertreter in ihrer
berichterstattung oder auch als quelle
noch mal anschauen können wir reden ja
momentan über wirksamkeit und da ist
alles richtig was die kollegen gesagt
haben aber es gibt daten und diese
veröffentlichung ist aus dem dezember
verfügbar wo genau eine sehr schnelle
darstellung ist wir reden über die nun
antworten in den verschiedenen
altersgruppen
also über 70 56 bis 70 und bis 55 und
das sollten wir auch jetzt noch im
hinterkopf behalten
mit 2 und wohnt in dieser altersgruppe
sehr gute und vergleichbare antikörper
antworten gesehen und das ist wie gesagt
dass dieses feature ist verfügbar und es
ist eine sehr anschauliche darstellung
lohmann sieht wiesen die antike abläufe
in den wirksamkeitsstudien waren wenige
in dieser hatte zwar nicht genug leute
wahrscheinlich dass das wetter heute
hören woher diese
man kann zu testen aber dass ich möchte
noch einmal diskussion einwerfen ist es
nicht gezeigt worden dass keine guten
antikörper gebildet werden im gegenteil
diese studie aus dezember im moment habe
ich veröffentlicht zeigt sehr gut wenn
die betroffenen zwei impfungen bekommen
bei einer info sieht man eine abmahnung
nicht gute in so eine weniger gute
entwicklung von antikörpern aber
ansonsten sind die die kurven für die
antikörper entwicklung in allen anderen
altersgruppen gleich und da sollte man
noch mal zu diesen diese publikation
verlinken wo man auch dieses element in
die diskussion einzubringen weil ich
glaube dass vermischt sich ein bisschen
danke in dieser frage
dieses ziel erreichen sind
[Musik]
ich würde mal sagen zu der fachlichen
frage sagt herr pocher sowie das weil
wir ja eine solche verordnung in engster
abstimmung mit dem robert-koch-institut
erarbeiten und auf die fachliche
expertise dort verlassen das denke ich
mir ja nicht in meinem büro aus sondern
es wird ja nach der stellungnahme aus
der wissenschaft und der beteiligten
erarbeitet und deswegen professor wieder
bitte ja also zunächst einmal ist klar
dass momentan die fünf prozent noch
nicht erreicht werden die frau ist ja
gerade am 19
in kraft getreten und die anreize gelten
für jedes labor
sie gelten ja nicht nur für großraum-
und wo es gibt eine menge labore
es gibt auch gesundheitsämter es gibt
landeslabor es gibt eine reihe von
laboren in deutschland die sequenzierung
durchführen das ist übrigens eine stärke
von deutschland und das heißt also es
gilt für alle labore das zu nutzen und
wir gehen davon aus dass der anreiz der
dort geschaffen wurde dass der durchaus
hoch ist das heißt also wir gehen davon
aus dass das ausgefüllt wird wir haben
jetzt auf der website kriterien den
laboren gegeben so dass sie diese fünf
prozent wie sie die proben aussuchen
sollen das ist der viel entscheidendere
punkt wenn sie sich vorstellen dass etwa
ein labor die ersten fünf proben die in
der woche oder die ersten fünf prozent
diesen der woche hat einfach
sequenzieren es dann ist die
aussagekraft natürlich schlecht so
brauchen halbwegs repräsentative proben
dass das betone ich immer wieder weil
das viel wichtiger ist als viele proben
zu machen sie müssen gezielt gemacht
werden das zweite was ja dazu kommt ist
wir haben ja nach wie vor die anderen
wege
das heißt also wir haben unter anderem
sentinel natürlich in
etabliert wohnt ja nach wie vor sentinel
praxen auch proben direkt einsenden also
einfach proben einsenden und das robert
koch institut wird natürlich auch selber
dann solche probensequenz analysieren
das heißt also diese ganzen wege die wir
neben den reinen wegen haben über sie
grenzen die beschreiten wir natürlich
zusätzlich und etwas hatte ich noch
sagen möchte ist natürlich wird jedoch
nach wie vor gibt es ja auch unabhängig
von der sequenzierung das bitte ich sie
alle auch zu verstehen
es wird ja immer wieder dann tests geben
pcr tests mit denen man dann diese
mutation gezielt suchen kann also die
vorstellung dass für diese variante nur
finden wenn wir alles sequenzieren ist
schlichtweg nicht korrekt sondern es
werden immer wieder test entwickelt von
den eher stellen was man gezielte
variante sucht und damit kann man
natürlich die varianten vorkommen
deutlich höher suchen deutlich stärker
finden was das entscheidende ist bei den
fünf prozent und wenn wir uns gesagt
wenn es unter 70.000 sind pro woche
dann kann sogar bis zu 10% sequenziert
werden das entscheidende ist dass das
eine gewisse repräsentativität hat und
etwas worauf ich sie auch hinweisen
möchte es ist wer in zukunft nicht mehr
varianten auftreten das ist biologisch
sehr plausibel und je mehr wir impfen
desto mehr varianten werden nach
auftreten und der entscheidende punkt
ist an der mit den fünf oder als wenn es
bei mir geht es immer unter 70.000 pro
woche rund 70.000 zehn prozent wenn wir
dann immer sehen repräsentativ welche
varianten bau unterwegs sind und das ist
ein sehr guter und wichtiger weg
repräsentativität ist deutlich wichtiger
als masse
also wir werden ja wir haben wir den
auftrag erhalten in der ersten
februarwoche und wenn nicht ist das
nächste woche einen bericht zu schreiben
in diesem bericht werden wir dazu nach
bestem wissen und gewissen auskunft
geben wir werden zum einen berichten
darüber
es gibt labore die jetzt auch ein
querschnitt machen bestimmten pc
untersuchen da wurden 100 1000 tests
verwendet werden berichtet nächste woche
erstellen und dann wenn wir uns dazu
äußern
eine frage von carlo in gera nbc news an
das paul-ehrlich-institut gibt es schon
eine zusammenarbeit mit russischen
stellen zur möglichen zulassung von
sputnik 5 innerhalb der eu für die frage
zusammenarbeit würde ich das nicht
nennen denn wir haben ja eine andere
aufgabe als die entwickler aber ja es
gab anfragen und auch schon kontakte
dazu das paul ehrlich institut
unterstützt sehr international
das heißt wir haben die russischen
kollegen schon auch über
videokonferenzen regulatorisch beraten
im hinblick auf zwei aspekte einmal den
aspekt möglicherweise nochmals zu
erläutern was die europäischen
voraussetzung für zulassungen
herstellung und ähnliches sind zum
anderen auch ebenen wir den weg wenn das
vorhaben so ist auch zu europäischen
arzneimittelagentur weil da noch eine
beratung im kollegenkreis mit den
anderen europäischen
arzneimittelbehörden der mitgliedsländer
gefunden werden kann
das heißt solche kontakte laufen und wir
arbeiten darauf hin dass vielleicht
herstellung städten auch in europa
ermöglicht werden dass die herstellung
wenn sie woanders stattfindet unseren
ansprüchen entspricht und dass dann auch
die datenlage so sein müsste wenn ein
solcher impfstoff in frage kommt in
europa zugelassen zu werden
das hat unseren ansprüchen
qualitätskriterien entspricht dankeschön
24 jahren dreh bis rheinische post fragt
ein professor wieder was können
einreisebeschränkungen wie sie derzeit
etwa flughäfen diskutiert werden
tatsächlich aus sicht des
robert-koch-institutes bringen brauchen
wie sie wir haben in manchen
modellierungen haben wir ihnen ja auch
vorgestellt
wie der eintrag ist von außen bzw
natürlich auch wie wir selber wenn wir
nach außen reisen auch dinge austragen
es gab zeiten da haben wir etwa 15
prozent der fälle die nach deutschland
eingetragene und kam vom ausland zeiten
wo es höher war
prinzipiell sind alle reisenden nicht
gemacht werden hilfreich die
verschleppung von viren zu unterdrücken
das ist so und das gilt für beide
richtungen ich möchte noch mal sagen
auch in deutschland werden natürlich
zukünftig mehr varianten auftreten und
darum ist mobilität ist einer der
treiber von pandemien ist frage herr
reitschuster
[Musik]
also die fall definition des rk ii ich
kann mich nicht erinnern dass die sich
über letzten monate geändert hat fälle
pcr bestätigte positiv pcr bestellte
gefälle sind fälle die haben wir immer
so gestellt was wir geändert haben ist
natürlich seitdem die anti gen tests
eingeführt wo die er nicht genauso ein
also die die die qualität des
ergebnisses eine anti gen test ist nicht
übereinstimmte qualität einer pizza und
da haben wir ich weiß nicht mehr genau
wann vor einigen monaten haben wir dann
die empfehlung herausgegeben
das positive an die gentests mit pcr
nachuntersucht werden müssen aber die
fall definitionen haben wir nicht
angepasst
also noch mal wenn wir im rahmen von
ausbrüchen es gibt ja zwei gründe warum
man diagnostik macht der eine grund ist
eigentlich eine person ist symptomatisch
und diese person sollte ich dann fest
lassen übrigens haben wir zurzeit rund
zwei millionen test kapazität und wir
testen zurzeit rund eine millionen in
der letzten woche war das so also die
hausärzte können auch intensiver wieder
testen das vielleicht ganz gut
moment das noch mal zu sagen alle die
eine indikation ist die man hat ein
symptom mann ist krank und möchte
getestet werden das ist klar
die zweite indikation ist natürlich die
wenn sie in einen ausbruch sind und dann
ist es ja klar dass dann im rahmen des
ausbruchs und der kontakt nach
verfolgung ein gesundheitsamt das ist
deren ureigene aufgabe natürlich dann
auch leute testet den nicht
symptomatisch
das hängt ja immer vom jeweiligen
ausbruch geschehen auch das entscheidet
dann entsprechend das gesundheitsamt
dazu gibt's auch empfehlungen
das hat dann nichts mit symptomatik zu
tun sondern die verhinderung der
ausbreitung eines virus und dann werden
natürlich darunter fallen auch menschen
die allen thematischen
also die meisten menschen sterben gar
nicht auf intensivstationen sondern also
die mehrheit der todesfälle tritt
außerhalb von intensivstationen auf aber
natürlich ist von den menschen die auf
intensivstation kommen das sind ja alles
mit menschen die schwer krank sind und
das von denen natürlich wiederum viele
sterben ist ist leider so dass da wenn
sie gar nicht auch intensiv müssen
werden sie nicht so stark krank das
heißt also dass das muss man natürlich
sehen aber ich verstehe ihre frage
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so richtig
ja offensichtlich ist das so klar also
offensichtlich sterben viele ältere
außerhalb des krankenhauses jahr
das sieht man ja sehr deutlich an den
zahlen den todeszahlen schon seit vielen
wochen
man sieht dass also die die die
todeszahlen wir haben wir verschiedene
grafiken das eine sind die zahlen die
uns gemeldet werden
die haben ja oft in verzug die menschen
sind ja oft früher verstorben weil wir
die daten ja später kriegen aber es ist
natürlich so dass viele menschen
außerhalb des krankenhauses sterben und
dadurch dass die inzidenz bei den
hochaltrigen sehr stark zugenommen
wir haben immer noch die höchste instanz
bei den über 90-jährigen bei den über
80-jährigen ist natürlich die anzahl der
menschen die dort sterben deutlich höher
und diese menschen werden nicht immer
ins krankenhaus eingeliefert sie sterben
teilweise eben auch sehr akut ja das ist
so
also ich bin wissenschaftler ich bin
keine opposition oder oder sonstwas
sondern davon ist mir nichts bekannt ich
weiß nur folgendes im frühjahr die
situation war eine völlig andere dass
das müssen sie wirklich immer im kopf
haben
im frühjahr war die pandemie in erster
linie getrieben durch junge menschen
wenn sich dann noch erinnern daran
dieser klassiker die skifahrer das waren
ja keine 80 jährigen und hochaltrigen
menschen sollen die ersten waren junge
menschen die die krankheit nach
deutschland gebracht haben
der anteil der alten und hochaltrigen
war in dieser ersten welle deutlich
geringer weil es damals uns gelungen ist
die welle schnell zu brechen und damals
hatten wir noch gar nicht so viele
ausbrüche in altersheim als was jetzt
haben also wenn sie sich jetzt
prozentual anschauen die anzahl der
ausbrüche in altersheim prozentual zur
anzahl der fälle im vergleich zu früher
dann ist der quotient jetzt deutlich
ungünstiger wir haben einfach viel mehr
ausbrüche ich wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere hat mir letzte woche 900
ausbrüche in alten ein ja also dieses
klientel ist einfach nicht genügend
geschützt
das ist einfach die wahrheit und dann
ist das risiko dass die versterben
deutlich höher als junge menschen dazu
passt die frage weil ich jetzt etwas
verwohnten vereinbarungen von wem mit
wem am ende ist es doch eine ärztliche
entscheidung
ich frag mich nur den vorwurf an wen das
ist am ende eine ärztliche entscheidung
im einzelfall
und sonst nichts
das ist auch richtig so wer soll es
sonst entscheiden wenn ich die
behandelnden ärzte wie in einer akku
situation die behandlung
dazu passt im weitesten sinn die frage
von kollegen buchsteiner media panel
ersparen in den wird in den pflegeheimen
flächendeckend und regelmäßig getestet
fragte kollege und wie erklären sie sich
dass zahlen anteil der toten in heimen
immer noch so hoch ist also zuerst
einmal ist es ja so dass hat der
professor wieder gerade angedeutet dass
die zahl der wo die meldung der
todesfälle oft ein verzug von bis zu
zwei bis drei wochen hat deswegen muss
man auch sehr aufpassen dass das jetzt
sozusagen nicht alles binnen letzter 24
stunden todesfälle sind sondern
gemeldete in den letzten 24 stunden
gemeldete fälle sind die aber eben zum
teil auch schon vorher statt weil er
eben diese todesfälle es vorher gegeben
hat und die gemälde verfüge da sind weil
zum teil aus den kliniken aus anderen
bereichen in dem stress der gerade ist
jetzt deskriptive nie entschuldigen
sondern erklären
dieser verzug entsteht weil man sich ja
als 100 warum gehen die infektionszahlen
so runter aber wir sehen das noch nicht
in den todeszahlen das hat eben auch mit
dem melde verzug zu tun was die pflege
einrichtungen angeht wird deutlich
umfassender getestet ich habe jetzt
keinen abschließend überblick über
33.000 ambulante und stationäre pflege
dienste ich kann nur sagen dass wir die
rechtliche und die finanzielle grundlage
schon vor monaten geschaffen haben für
deutlich mehr tests in den
pflegeeinrichtungen ambulant wie
stationär
das ist die unterstützung gibt jetzt ja
auch noch mal zusätzlich von angebotenen
kräften
und ich mir manchmal schon will ist sehr
unterschiedlich es gibt einrichtungen im
übrigen so dass auch problemlos
funktioniert und wo jetzt auch die
kräfte dankbar angenommen werden
aber manchmal hat man auch den eindruck
die angebote die gerade gemacht werden
wo jetzt wirklich das geschultes
personal die kosten fragen sind geklärt
am ende muss man sozusagen anfordern ich
möchte schon frage warum das nicht auch
noch etwas mehr passiert als das im
moment dann der fall ist
wir jedenfalls haben rechtlich und
finanziell seit oktober die grundlage
geschaffen und jetzt gibt es ja eben
auch darüber hinaus noch zusätzlich das
ausgebildete personal im angebot
ich kann nur alle pflegeeinrichtungen
dazu momentan ist auch zu nutzen
vielleicht eine kurze ergänzung in
unserem situationsbericht gibt es einmal
die woche meine nach meiner erinnerung
ist das dienstags eine kurve wo die
sterbezahlen mit dem sterbedatum
dargestellt sind da sehen sie die also
das ist ja das was dann an dem tag an
dem die person leider verstorben ist und
das hat eben verzug und dann sehen sie
waren die höchsten sterbezahlen waren
das war glaube ich um weihnachten herum
habe ich nicht so ganz im kopf die kurve
ist da die können sie sich anschauen ich
meine dienstags war dass der titel
[Musik]
ich finds ja schön wenn sie auch den
nächsten satz von herrn seehofer mit
zitieren würde mich richtig erinnere war
dass das aber nichts hilft jetzt im
nachhinein alles zu kritisieren und
besser zu wissen in etwa sinngemäß oder
nein aber ich finde den neuen ländern
ist das gesamt zitat ja dann in seiner
wirkung das weil am ende natürlich im
zweifel meinte immer auch früher
bestellen können das ist aber am ende ja
auch prozesse gewesen sind wo die
europäische kommission verhandelt hatte
ich so wie das müssen sie die
europäischen kommission und die
verhandlungsprozess nachvollziehen
erweisen sich der tägliche befund in der
öffentlichen debatte
man hätte früher bestellen sollen
der ist hätte schon ist nicht neu
womöglich alles täuscht der sind wir
schon des öfteren erfolgt er hilft mir
aber nur nicht und der hilft im übrigen
auch nicht für die frau am beispiel
bringen bei und weise hatten geplant 100
millionen dosen bis ende letzten jahres
zu produzieren dann hat das produktions
probleme gegeben und sie konnten am ende
nur 50 millionen produkt nur die hälfte
produzieren bis zum ende letzten jahres
die ersten produktions themen hatte
schon letztes jahr gegeben weil
impfstoff produktion aufbauen der feld
irgendwas aus irgendein kleines
stückchen es ist so komplex dann steht
alles still
und damit war klar wir alle staaten mit
deutlich weniger dosen weil ob hundert
millionen oder 50 millionen für die
erste lieferung zur verfügung stehen
macht offenkundig ein unterschied wäre
es besser gewesen die produktion wäre
100 millionen gewesen
insofern kann ich jetzt an jedem punkt
in dem prozess der letzten zwölf monate
eine stelle finden wir immer sein kann
dem wissen von heute immer aber das
hilft mir doch jetzt nicht am 29 januar
2021 ist mein größtes bestreben dass wir
zug um zug tag um tag stunde um stunde
alles dafür tun damit schnellstmöglich
so viele impfdosen wie möglich von einem
zugelassenen wirksamen impfstoff in
deutschland zur verfügung steht und das
mit den herstellern dass am ende ist ja
der virus das wäre aus unserer gegner
und nicht die pharmaindustrie oder nicht
wir gegenseitig über alle politischen
verantwortungsebenen oder so das virus
ist der gegner und wir tun uns zusammen
um es in der pandemie zu besiegen
und darum geht's mit nowaks finden
verhandlungen statt der europäischen
kommission ist auch schon in abfrage
welcher mitgliedsstaat wie viel ordern
möchte und auch die bundesrepublik
deutschland wird sich wie in jeder
bestellung auf europäischer ebene daran
beteiligen dass es zu bestellungen
kommen kann also in einem großen volumen
wir bestellen ja auch nach ich will nur
mal sagen übrigens die erste
verbindliche bestellung die größte
größte volumen hat die europäische union
bei beyond ich gemacht
der pfizer ceo selbst gesagt die eu
bestellung war die grösste vollständige
bestellung die anderen hatten halt viele
optionen gemacht die eu hat voll
bestellt und auch dort haben wir ja
schon nachbestellt wir werden bei
moderner nachbestellen
ich bin gerade in verhandlung auch mit
anderen auch was produktionsstätten in
die sphären zum teil produktionsstätten
zb nun am beispiel des werden
produktionsstätten seien die zum teil
erst im vierten quartal möglicherweise
einen unterschied machen kann man ja
sagen viertes quartal ist aber noch
lange hin bringt das dennoch was ihr
wollt doch im sommer allem warum bringt
das was weil wir heute nicht wissen
welche mutationen es gibt es kann
notwendig werden dass aufgrund von
mutationen wir neue impfen müssen und
deswegen müssen die verträge natürlich
die wir für diesen zeitraum vorsehen
beinhalten dass dann der impfstoff ins
board der mma im stoff angepasst wird
oder was ja auch wir noch nicht wissen
wann es ein booster braucht braucht es
nach 12
monaten nach zwei jahren nach fünf
jahren überhaupt jemals ein
das gibt der in stoff für die kennt
jeder aus anderen zusammenhängen dann
müssen sie alle zwei jahre zur impfung
und es gibt andere impfstoffe die müssen
so einmal im leben kriegen und danach
ist für den rest des lebens die
immunität da das wissen wir noch gar
nicht und ich finde es vorausschauend
auch mit den erfahrungen die wir gemacht
haben aus den letzten zwölf monaten und
denen die sie gerade angesprochen haben
dass wir jetzt schon auch über das erste
impfangebot hinaus für deutschland und
europa und mengen sichern für mögliche
booster impfungen für mögliche mutations
impfungen und falls wir da nicht
brauchen sollten können wir immer noch
für den rest der welt einen guten dienst
damit tun und deswegen werden wir auch
zusätzliche bestellungen machen die über
das erste impfangebot hinausgehen ich
habe noch mehrere fragen die sich mit
der inthronisierung beschäftigt fast das
einfach mal zusammen
menschen mit behinderungen fordern eine
höhere priorisierung auch lehrer und
polizisten und ein kollege lenz vom hd
radio berichtet von feuerwehr
mitarbeitern die sich alles schon haben
impfen lassen was eigentlich gar nicht
vorgesehen dass in der priorität 2 sind
wie bewerten sie das herr sparen also
zuerst einmal ist es ja auch dort die
ständige impfkommission insbesondere die
aus den daten die da sind jeweils auch
die impfempfehlungen aus arbeitet auch
mit blick auf feuer kranken übrigens hat
die aktuelle neue empfehlungen die in
erarbeitung ist oder zum teil schon
überarbeitet wurde auch die frage welche
vorerkrankung führt zu welchem risiko
noch einmal überarbeitet aufgrund neuer
erkenntnis lage und damit eben sich auch
prioritäten mit bestimmten
krankheitsbildern sozusagen verändert in
der im freien folge und das wird
weiterhin so passieren dass das
wissenschaftlich ausgewertet wird aus
der erkenntnislage und daraufhin eben
die priorisierung dann auch überarbeitet
wird was wichtig ist was die ständige
impfkommission zusätzlich empfiehlt was
aber auch immer schon gegolten hat ist
natürlich das im einzelfall und einige
länder haben dafür sogar kleine
kommissionen gebildet ich weiß es sicher
aus hamburg und bremen
im einzelfall bei einer bestimmten
vorerkrankungen der seltenen erkrankung
die möglicherweise statistisch gar nicht
auftauchen kann sozusagen in den
priorisierungen dass dort im einzelfall
dann auch früher geimpft werden kann
wenn das eben eine entscheidung ärztlich
vor ort dann ist das zweite was die
feuerwehr angeht oder anderes ich tippe
mal das stellt ab auf der impfung von
dosen die am abend übrig geblieben sind
ich bleibe bei der prämisse alles ist
besser als wegwerfen und wir wissen dass
impfdosen wenn sie nicht in einem
bestimmten zeitraum verimpft werden dann
nicht mehr genutzt werden können wenn
also am abend an dem impfzentrum noch
impfdosen da sind die jetzt verkauft
werden müssen dann macht es sinn eine
logik zu haben nach der man die vernunft
und ich weiß auch dass die ersten landes
und lokalen behörden die auch haben dass
man eben zum beispiel die rettungskräfte
einsatzkräfte krisenstabs kräfte
medizinisches personal dann das auch
sozusagen in der nähe ist schnell
erreicht werden kann dann hilft das ist
ja grundsätzlich auch einfach vernünftig
aber noch vernünftig ist es vor allem
dann wenn es auch eine logik hat
deswegen finde ich es gut dass dafür
ebenso zusagen für den fall der fälle
kriterien erarbeitet worden sind aber
das schlechteste wäre wenn wir dieses
knappe gut des impfstoffes am abend
nicht nutzen würden wenn was tatsächlich
übrig geblieben sein sollte warum auch
immer weil jemand nicht gekommen ist zum
vereinbarten termin weil es gelungen ist
aus einem fläschchen statt sechs sogar
sieben dosen zu ziehen was ist ja auch
gelegentlich gibt wenn das entsprechend
gefüllt worden ist einfach im
produzentin prozess dann sollten diese
dosen auch genutzt werden alles andere
wäre unklug
wissen sie ich bleibt einer devise
einfach treu in dieser pandemie
ich fange ich an mit diesen finger
aufeinander herum zeigen
ich kann mich kein aufzugeben
ich kann auch zu jedem landkreis und zu
jedem land und zu jedem eu
mitgliedsstaat eine schlaue bemerkung
abgeben und jeder kann das im zweifel zu
dem was der bund tut aber hilft uns das
hilft uns dass wir alle wissen dass
gerade wir die wir politische
verantwortung haben ob in einem
landkreis in einem land im bund in der
europäischen kommission dass wir gerade
unter stress mit viel unwissenheit und
unsicherheit entscheidungen zu treffen
haben
jeder von uns jede jeden tag zig mal
und deswegen kann ich halt nur dafür
werden wir sind gemeinsam in dieser
pandemie in dieser situation der
gemeinsamen feind ist das virus dass wir
uns am ende unterlagen und wenn was zu
besprechen ist dass wir miteinander
besprechen so wie ich das mit den 16
kolleginnen und kollegen in den ländern
tue mehrfach die woche
sr hört dann aber daneben vor allem auch
gemeinsam in dieser pandemie arbeit nun
kämpfen und das gilt ja nicht nur für
die die politische verantwortung haben
sondern für alle anderen auch das heißt
nicht nicht über fehler zu reden wir
können nur lernen wenn wir über das was
nicht optimal gelaufen ist
auch reden wenn wir es auch kritisch tun
aber im konstruktiv kritisch und man
weiß vielleicht in der einordnung
die der besonderen situation in der wir
entscheiden auch in den vergleichen die
medizin gerecht wird
wir müssen mit blick auf die uhr langsam
zum schluss kommen zwei fragen noch herr
kollege
die letzte sein jetzt müssen wir uns
noch mal eine frage zuerst einmal würde
ich auch ein professor willy bieten noch
einmal darzustellen was wir bereits seit
märz letzten jahres an zusätzlichen
sequenzierung anstrengungen und
projekten unternommen haben auch beim
robert-koch-institut und zusammen mit
anderen ja es ist wahr großbritannien
und dänemark sequenz hier in
traditionell schon vor dieser pandemie
mehr als nahezu alle anderen
europäischen länder
und auch hier kann man im nachhinein
sagen mehr wäre immer besser gewesen
dann aber wir haben ja seit märz
durchaus mehr sequenziert jetzt noch
einmal nachgezogen und im übrigen wenn
eine institution und eine berufsgruppe
tag und nacht zugang hatte und hat dann
sind es die virologen und ich freue mich
über jeden hinweis den ich so früh wie
möglich immer wieder aufs neue kriege
dass man jetzt sagt man hat irgendwie
schon vor der pandemie hinweise gegeben
ja das gilt für viele bereiche werden
2012 ganzen dicken bericht im deutschen
bundestag über das was eigentlich besser
alles schon da gewesen wäre als die
pandemie begonnen hat das ist ohne
zweifel so
auch das muss man ja miteinander so
aufarbeiten das einst jetzt nicht wieder
passiert dass wir nach der pandemie
berichte schreiben
das hätte besser laufen sollen und dann
daraus nichts folgt sondern dass wir
schon dann sehr zügig auch beginnen
daraus daraus zu lernen aber wir haben
eben wie gesagt schon bereits ab
frühjahr letzten jahres auch dort
durchaus stärkere anstrengungen gehabt
ja also zunächst mal ist das jetzt mit
der verordnung und der technologie die
wir aufstellen sich an durchbruch und
ich hoffe auch dass dieser durchbruch
bezüglich der molekularen zu wählen es
auch für andere infektionserreger gilt
wo wir das ja auch brauchen können das
muss man auch ganz klar sagen also was
wir damals gemacht haben das war glaube
ich im februar zusammen mit dem
konsiliarlabor wir haben in deutschland
so ein tolles netzwerk von referenz und
konsiliarlabor das haben wir seit 20
jahren und das eigentlich die basis für
ganz ganz viele tolle qualität die wir
gerade in der diagnostik und
epidemiologie haben konsiliarlabor
posten gibt es ja eben weil es eben
fachleute gibt diese hohe qualität aber
es gibt auch andere konsiliarlabor für
andere regeln wenn wir im februar
entsprechenden antrag zusammen verfasst
um die sequenzierung zu erhöhen und das
haben wir auch genehmigt bekommen und
seit ich glaube 25 03 oder so ist der
serbe will ich vorne seitdem arbeiten
wir auch dran
die aussage dass hier in einem blindflug
sind das ist eine aussage die ich
einfach nicht nachvollziehen kann ja es
ist
wir haben kein detailwissen aber schauen
sie wir wissen zum beispiel dass diese
variante hier ist wir haben inzwischen
einige hinweise wir wissen dass die die
sogenannte die also mit der vereine
staaten in schon mit dem vereinten
königreich zum beispiel dass die am
weitesten verbreitet ist wir haben aber
auch schon die beiden anderen
wurden auch bereits schon gefunden das
heißt wir betrachten das und ich will
nur noch mal sagen die maßnahmen und das
ist wirklich immer das credo dass ich
kann es gar nicht oft genug sagen die
maßnahmen abstand halten kontakt
reduktion preisen einschränken masken
tragen hygiene maßnahmen die helfen
gegen alle waren erstmal das ist ein
ganz wichtiger punkt ja die helfen gegen
alle varianten und und wenn wir jetzt
herausfinden dass varianten gibt die und
das ist inzwischen sehr überzeugend dass
zumindest die variante b 1 17 die mit
dem vereinigten königreich in
zusammenhang erstmals doch gefunden
wurde
die wird stärker übertragen sie hat eine
höhere transmission dann müssen wir die
maßnahmen natürlich konsequent weiter
fahren ja und dann wäre noch mal schauen
wie es aussieht denn im mitte februar
denn die maßnahmen die wir jetzt haben
die helfen aber ich erzähle ihnen eine
geschichte um wird klar zu machen was
immer noch passiert es haben leute über
silvester eine tolle party gemacht aus
dem raum flensburg sind mehrere hundert
leute haben in sind nach dänemark
gefahren haben eine party gemacht ja
jetzt haben wir 180 fälle wenn leute
eine tolle party gemacht haben für die
ich wenig verständnis ab jetzt auch
gerne partikel mord silvester und davon
sind 44 von diesen 180 sind zum beispiel
diese b 11 7 variante ja also lassen sie
uns doch einfach auf das wesentliche
schauen dass wir diesen verdammten virus
keine chance geben sich auszubreiten wie
immer die variante heißt
und darum haben wir die tools die wir
haben lassen sie uns die nutzen und wir
werden nächste woche einen bericht
zeigen und in dem bericht werden wir
sehen wie viel wir auf die variante
vorkommt oder die häufig nicht vorkommt
wenn man einige ausbrüche hier im
humboldt krankenhaus da ist auch sind
glaube ich bislang von den patienten
sind elf diagnostiziert mit b1 17 naja
dann wird man natürlich diesen ausbruch
intensiv mit den regulären methoden
bearbeiten wir schlagen vor dass war
dadurch dass die transmission erhöhte
das war die maßnahmen noch strikter
vielleicht setzt das man noch
portierungen macht wo man versucht die
jene die mit der variante infiziert sind
noch ein bisschen anders zu korrigieren
als die mit den anderen varianten ja das
tun wir den akuten ausbruch noch mal die
ganzen maßen
die wir fahren in schützen uns vor der
ausbreitung von allen varianten das ist
das a und o und die anderen dinge die
wir dann noch zusätzlich erfahren
die setzen wir dann noch zusätzlich bei
den massnahmen obendrauf wir müssen die
maßnahmen konsequent durchziehen und bis
mitte februar auf jeden fall und dann
sehen wir wie weit die instanzen
untergehen ich persönlich habe ein
zu der letzten frage ich habe
unterschrieben mit einem aufruf der im
letzten dezember im la zeit publiziert
wurde prise mann und kollegen und da
habe ich das steht 10 10 pro 100000 ist
das ziel und das war ein cooles zielen
und das habe ich schon früher gesagt ich
habe gesagt wenn ich mir was wünschen
könnte das ist in die obergrenze die wir
wollen in deutschland ich gesagt die
obergrenze werden vielleicht zu 1000
fälle am tag ja man wünsche mir 0 ich
wünsche mir auch zero wird aber wenn wir
1000 pro tag haben dann sind zwar
insofern safe als dass wir dann alles
beherrschen können schnell reagieren
können unsere krankenhäuser gut
funktionieren und das ganze
gesundheitswesen dass alles gut managen
kann nur einsatz
wir müssen schluss machen ich möchte
noch die frage beantworten die zum
master seine kämpfe soft gestellt wurde
die datenlage ist ja nicht schlecht die
wirksamkeit ist da aber in den
klinischen prüfung war nicht genügend
probanden da bestimmten altersgruppe mir
klar und wirksam kreis feststellen zu
können
die frage wurde gestellt wie schnell
kann das geändert werden sehr schnell
wir verlangen von der firma seit einigen
wochen eine weitere interimsanalyse
laufenden klinischen prüfung und hier
kann sich schon und bessere datenlage
gleich ergeben herzlichen dank
ich habe sowohl online als auch im saal
noch ein haufen fragen wie ich die wir
nicht beantworten konnten
das tut mir leid aber das zeigt die
dringlichkeit diese veranstaltung
regelmäßig weiterzuführen ich bedanke
mich bei den gästen im saal ich bedanke
mich nach hamburg dass die rede und
antwort gestanden haben herzlichen
eigentlich schief bundespressekonferenz
[Musik]